think think about the the absolute
insanity
that is the policies being pushed by
these democratic politicians
how they keep making things worse what
people just are scared
of of not fitting in so it's it's
absolute mob mentality right
you get you get the uh story of
lynchings you get the story of people
marching with pitchforks and torches
they get wrapped up in the mob and they
just do what the mob does and this is no
different
the like twitter for instance is it is a
constant mob
yeah it is all mob mentality it's people
piling on so people join in because they
want to fit in and they're scared
so what is up happenings new york city
right it's
it's horrible horrifying yes we have a
story homelessness mental illness crime
is skyrocketing locals and tourists
believe the town has lost its essence
some of these photos i don't even know
if i can show you because new york is
bad
like there's a woman laying a mentally
ill homeless man
is seen laying in the street blocking
traffic in times square whoa
you look at venice there's i mean this
is brutal
constant emergency zone calls for change
mount as homeless encampment fills
venice boardwalk crime increases
imagine after watching all of this
imagine after watching what happened in
portland with you know constant riots
fire bombs
people are like well you know but i
don't want people to think i'm a trump
supporter
so i'll vote for the democrat again yeah
and i think what's really shocking
is that a lot of the people who are in
these areas these urban areas like new
york
they've been there for so long they
think it's normal i remember
last time i was in la i was talking to
someone who was from l.a and she asked
like so are you going to be moving down
here and i said i
i don't think i could frankly she's like
oh really why not i was like well
there's
you know there's a lot of poverty
there's a lot of crime a lot of
homelessness and she was like what
really
it's like yeah and even
just recently i was in new york with uh
sean actual justice warrior and
you know he was driving us through the
city and you know we were asking him so
is this a good area is this a good area
and i remember
like he we would be driving somewhere
and he was like yeah yeah this is a
really nice area and like liam and i
would my husband would like look at each
other and back like it does not look
like a nice area and that's just i think
a lot of people are desensitized to
you know seeing stuff like we saw a drug
deal on the side of the street biggest
rat i've ever seen in my life
but that's normal for them so for these
people who have been living
no a little bit of a fence that's bad
that's not good yeah
for these people who've been living in
these cities for the past year they're
frogs boiling
they don't realize the temperature is
escalating just
every day another homeless tent every
day another crime a mugging
and now they're used to it and i know
this from experience because you know
living in chicago
i remember when i when i leave chicago
i'm like wow like you know carjackings
and shootings are like a rare thing huh
it's like well not when you're in
chicago it's like every once a month or
at least you hear gunshots going out and
you hear a story about a murder 800
murders
per year so you're getting a couple
murders per day that's
that's living life so when you live
there you're desensitized to all this
so the people who are living in new york
and there's crime and there's escalating
mental illness and problems
and benefits are worse the train service
is worse
it's just normal every day they add one
more grain of sand to that heap and
eventually the city's trash and
people just live in it l.a though people
are noticing my friends in l.a are
posting about it like dude you'll see
under the underpass there's just like
tents tents way way more i was there in
2010 i was in venice i lived in navy and
pacific right on the beach like a block
from the beach
and they had passed legislation right
around that time that they could no
longer camp overnight
in the parking lot they were like i'll
bring their rvs in and just living there
in the parking lot so eventually they
had to leave and come back
uh still pretty rare and it was to the
point where like if you wanted to park
on fifth street in venice and then walk
to the beach
you're better off parking in front of
like some homeless tents because they'll
be like hey and they'll watch your car
for you
you come back and they're super cool but
you know
like anything if it's overpopulated it
can become very very dangerous
so so here's two things are happening
right
we got a bunch of republicans they're
all gloating they're like you know that
you know that gif of uh
who who is it it's the was it the
godfather or whatever yeah where they're
like all laughing and smoking yeah
that's the godfather yeah that's so
that's the republican governors right
now
so we have the story red state governors
tell hannity town hall how harsh
lockdowns in liberal states have turned
democrat voters into republicans
who have fled and are now boosting their
economies cool
the democrats i think i can only imagine
want to destroy their cities
well it's hard to imagine people who are
in these cities and who see
everything getting worse like you know
the economy crime and all that stuff
and these places that have been in under
the same control for decades if not
generations
and it's like if you look at the state
of things now who do you have to blame
right i mean it's been the same people
in power so if you're one of those
residents and you're still voting for
those same people
i mean i've got a question like why
right that's insanity just doing the
same thing keeping the same party
same people in power and expecting it to
be different i kind of like i forget who
it was maybe kanye when it was talking
about like
blexit and voting for trump it's like
what do you have to lose
by trying something different if you're
in one of those situations where
you know like baltimore or detroit
you've kind of been sold out and just
completely forgotten about why not at
least try to change
stuff up democracy doesn't work does it
you know my thoughts on this
my thoughts are i prefer individual
liberty
over democracy and they're not always in
opposition to each other but they are
not synonymous
like i think you know democrats often
paint them as being and i do
you know service guarantees citizenship
i think there's
better metrics of measuring the
effectiveness and fairness of government
rather than
everybody gets a say yeah so
the the democrat democratic party is
literally becoming the democratic party
and the republican party is literally
becoming the republican party it's a bit
simplistic right now but uh republicans
like republicanism where you have states
and you have
these jurisdictions and you can live in
your state and have your rights
protected and the federal government you
know provides for the common defense and
things like that
and then you have the democratic party
which wants everyone to vote
all the time no matter how old you are
and then just get a majority
you know rule on things the ancient
greeks had two parties primarily the
democracy party and the oligarchy party
and uh it seems like we might still have
that with the democrats and the
republicans although
they're both a little more like it's all
funneling through a republic
now there is no like mob rule but we
still have like no it's all rats
and the oligarchs it's all mob rule what
do you mean well we have the republic in
the senate basically is supposed to like
be a stop gap to the mob rule and say
yeah and that's true that does
it the democrats complain about it
they're like why do 16 percent of the
population
have 50 percent of the say or whatever
yeah they talk about the senate and the
electoral college not being democratic
as if that's a fault rather than
the point of right system yeah they say
like did you know this it's like
yeah that's why it was created that way
it's to temper mob rule and
you know just the idea they talk about
things like they'll have polls like
this many people think it's unacceptable
to have hate speech yet
it's allowed or you know this many
people think we should have uh socialist
policies like i don't care what
how many other people support taking
away my rights they're my rights you
can't just take them away no matter how
many people are in favor of it
well that's what the guns are for yes
yeah and
they don't understand that either you
know what it is it really is a sorting
algorithm where you've got
people who just don't know don't care
and the people who do that's really it
they think they know and care but if
that were true they'd actually i don't
know like
fact check some of the things they read
but they don't conservatives do
conservatives constantly are are reading
other sources
and it's not perfect they're not always
correct but as i mentioned
fairly often there's that one study i
think i think it was pew
republicans get around a third of their
news from liberal sources
because they're comparing and
contrasting liberals don't
i think the uh uh jonathan heights
research and moral foundations
plays into this as well the the left
liberals only care about care and
fairness they only have two moral
foundations republicans have
six initially it was five another six so
uh libertarians have one
no it's true it's true one liberty
that's it it's amazing so you can take
these tests
and they tell you if you're a liberal
conservative or libertarian
libertarians don't care about anything
so long as it's liberty based
makes sense yeah so there's like some
really creepy questions in these in
these
in these tests but republicans tend to
have
every moral foundation which includes uh
purity
uh loyalty authority care fairness and
uh
let's say liberty no liberty i think
that's a six i can't remember
and the left is only care and fairness
what ends up happening then is
i could you go to someone and say hey i
propose
this policy and the only thing the left
cares about is
is it fair or caring about someone
that's why you see democrats literally
be like it's racist it's racist it's
racist
because that strikes at care and
fairness it's not fair racism is not
fair and then you go to conservatives
and they care about
loyalty supporting those who supported
you back the blue
authority you know also back the blue
purity
is you know purity isn't interesting
yeah like family
and and maintaining you know tradition
and things like that the life doesn't
care about any of that this is my
problem with fairness
this idea of fairness if there's two
people and you have one sandwich
what's fair you split it in half and
give each person half what if one of
those people is super hungry
the other one's totally full what's fair
you still split it in half and give them
each
and this guy can't even eat it so he
throws it away or do you give the entire
sandwich to the hungry person and then
you have to make that judgment call of
what's
fair and you have to believe that
they're telling the truth that they're
actually hungry
it's it's simple you take the sandwich
for yourself and you kill both
that's communism fairness no but that's
and communism is the most fair right
well usually and that's a great point
when it also comes to things like wealth
redistribution like
the communism is it fair and i think the
answer is no but
is it fair that someone who works all
day uh
gets the same amount of money as someone
who didn't work at all like is
is that fair i would say no and there's
this sense of like
almost equity that they equate with
fairness
and they equate that with justice but i
don't think that's fairness at all i
think we have different definitions of
what's rare
except like when it's in a family and
it's like a young kid it doesn't can't
work and then the parent does all the
work and provides equal for everybody
but i think there are people who are
communist and socialists who sees
who see everybody who isn't willing to
work or incapable as
as a child and we even saw that as like
one of the drafts of the green new deal
that even people who
did not want to work would be provided
for this is this is here's the
philosophical question
ian if you saw a beautiful
rare butterfly flapping around doing its
thing and then it got stuck on a
spider's web
would you free it no why not
uh i don't know it's not really my place
would you free it
no i don't like bugs you know i don't
care if it's a butterfly yeah the trash
take care of the trash
oh i wouldn't spider's got to eat yeah
that's this is just this
what i'm like who do i condone the
spider of the bible if you were caught
in a big spider web
i would for you mm-hmm right because
unless it was like a lord of the rings
no but you can use the uh what is that
the the light of uh
of you know what is this yeah yeah the
light of the last light of the elves or
whatever
yeah yeah there you go and then you'd
scare the spider away and cut it away
and i'd scream
yeah pull you down and carry off on my
shoulder it's interesting so i i went
out and i gathered a bunch of cicadas
right
because they're everywhere and i just
like attendants had 40 of them and just
dumped them in the chicken city
and the chickens just run up and start
just mashing their faces into them and
they're eating them like crazy
and i thought about like how brutal it
was that these things spend their lives
17 years 17 years of their lives
growing and getting ready to just get
that chance to reproduce and i took that
away from him
i do think however i'm helping because
the smart cicadas
when they when i got close would fly
away yeah and the dumb ones
that's evolution that's right yeah
you're contributing the gene pool well
that's kind of scary because then you're
contributing
to some sort of like super security
perspective
part of the antibiotics it means that
the next next round of cicadas will
avoid people
i don't know well maybe avoid them to
the point where you can't hear them that
would be nice
right now they're too loud anyway anyway
the point is
this is an important philosophical
question because a lot of people who
only care about care and fairness would
be like oh you've got to free the
butterfly
because butterflies are pretty and
spiders are gross and nasty ew icky
so it's a very childish way of looking
at things sure i mean i spiders i
actually like spiders with better than
butterflies almost soup i would catch
the butterfly and throw it in the spider
oh whoa
okay i'm kidding it seems like
superficial like this idea of fairness i
mean
obviously if someone's starving it's not
superficial
but it kind of is i mean it's not
obviously because if
when it comes to the human's life and a
human's death that's not superficial
let's let's stop for a second
you mentioned the sandwich thing right
yeah all right so one person's starving
and one person is not starving
why is the person starving exactly so so
what if the person's starving because
he's been sleeping
all day right and he doesn't work and
he's a misanthrope and the other guy
who's not starving
made the sandwich and he's not starving
because he makes sandwiches
and then what you take it away from him
and give to somebody who's not
contributing
this is a big challenge we face because
as you mentioned ian you would save me
from the giant spider
i would bless your heart uh however
there's big questions about that because
humans obviously want to save humans
because we're all humans we care about
each other
but then our natural tendency to save
each other results in people who are
a drain in the system being saved it's
really interesting i was talking about
the yeah
yeah i was talking to i remember who it
might have been daniel about chickens
yes and i think he was mentioning that
the roosters kill the baby roosters
yeah he's the expert yeah yeah he was
saying like they cull the weak wow
if the rooster sees a weak chick it'll
just mutilate it that metal
yeah super metal and it's like because
the idea is it's trying to make sure
that the flock stays strong
we don't do that anymore we cuddle the
week anymore yeah
well i mean like yes well look at sparta
war i mean just in general
we didn't have the social systems to
take care of people the way that we did
i mean also we didn't have the medicine
so it's like you know darwinism
if you screwed up you're going to die
but now medicine and technology and
society in general has advanced to the
point where we are able to keep the
people who would have been killed off
long ago
just around idiocracy yes so you you
guys have seen idiocracy right
parts of it so mike judge genius it's uh
it's where
they state in the beginning of the movie
it used to be the strongest would
survive
but because of human technology now
those who reproduced the most were being
rewarded by evolution
and i think what he missed in that sort
of i mean obviously the idea is that
stupid people reproduce more than
smarter which is true
but what he missed also was just in
general
people with a variety of ailments and
weaknesses
and you know i mean no disrespect
because i mean people want to live you
know what i mean i get there
uh we're humans we care about each other
so
that's that's a really there's a very
important philosophical question that
gets it
into a very into very dangerous
territory but i think so long as you
maintain libertarian values and just say
look i'll do my thing you do yours
we're probably better off but there's a
very deep philosophical question there
if you if you see somebody who is like
their leg is broken
and there's like a wolf running towards
them do you say oh well you know the
strong must survive
or do you help save the person if the
person's got like a genetic deformity in
their leg
and a wolf is running do you say oh well
the strong survive or do you save the
person
humans i think and this is good default
towards saving people and it's
unfortunate for us because
in the long term it's it's will probably
have a negative impact to a certain
degree
well and it's not it's not just that it
is like you were saying about idiocracy
the fact that not only are we trying to
save everybody but
it's almost like the people who are the
smartest and who would have potentially
the most to contribute
they tend toward nihilism nowadays
because
of you know economy politics lack of
spirituality whatever and they're less
likely to reproduce so then that is
dysgenic it's like if you look at
women the more educated a woman is the
less likely she has
she is to have children and the fewer
children she is so it's it's not
looking great for the long-term survival
of our species
yeah and i think what ends up happening
is you're going to get people who are
very powerful wealthy industrialists who
are going to
use their influence in power to say you
know what we're going to intervene and
we're going to force humans to do
something
i mean you look at how we treat hogs and
deer
when they get overpopulated humans have
no problem getting a helicopter with
some high-powered rifles and then
hunting down those hogs
like that they do this legit crazy when
there's like an overpopulation of feral
hogs they go and they call them they do
the same thing with deer
we have deer season for a reason too
many of them and then we get turkey
season too many of them
humans nobody culls humans except for
other humans in war
well i mean i i don't want to go down a
whole rabbit hole but there are
people who think that you know there are
a lot of abortion providers who go to
places specifically like africa
um and you know not just birth control
but actual abortions i mean there's an
argument to be made that is
in in a way especially if you subscribe
to the uh pro-life
mentality that is a form of calling it
you're saying there's too many of you
you can't survive you're breeding at too
fast a rate
we need to nip this in the bud it's
creepy yeah
there's no real i i don't i think humans
and it's not just in like developing
countries you can make the same argument
like the majority of abortion providers
are in
you know lower income neighborhoods yeah
in minority areas in minority areas
that's creepy it's creepy
this conversation's like so it's
impossible and i think humans are i just
screwed basically
what you said was the most one of the
most interesting things i've heard in a
long time is that
we we used the the weak used to die off
young
and so we the strong would breed and our
evolution was strong and now
the weak are kept around with medicine
and are breeding
and so our species is potentially seeing
that
side effect now and that results in
fascism and all sorts
of crazy deformities within our race it
results in
strong men authoritarian fascistic
leaders who are like
i'm gonna kill these people and that's
that's the creepy thing
i think that's why space travel is
probably our best approach we as humans
we can't tolerate
the the idea of just deciding who gets
to live or die
by some person's choice because an
individual will never be smart enough to
understand
you know a decentralized network is
infinitely better but through technology
more people are surviving even people
who normally wouldn't
what do we do i think space travel space
colonization rapid acceleration of
technology is probably the best approach
because we certainly want to do
everything to stop fascists but this is
a real philosophical philosophical
challenge
and you'll get the scary thing is people
who don't care about technology
many of these leftists who are saying
space travel's a waste of time bring the
money back to earth because they don't
realize the money was spent here in the
first place because
they're not literally shipping money to
mars like when you hire someone to build
a space ship you pay them on earth and
then they go and work and they buy food
anyway i i digress
these people are ideologically driven
and it's and it's creepy like when greta
tunberg
i think genuinely she is a a tool of
an authoritarian fascistic ideology
because she said she wanted to shut down
fossil fuels now which would result i
think in like
60 million deaths in a few weeks no joke
because starvation
and all diabetics would immediately die
if we lost
access to refrigeration and electricity
overnight because the shutting down of
coal
power plants hundreds of like i don't
know how many diabetics there are but
they they need insulin to be
refrigerated
we had the power go out the other day
refrigerator is gone like food spoils
just like that and so we set the
generator up we have the batteries
and we're hoping to keep our
refrigerator going heaven forbid you
actually rely on that like diabetics do
so when greta tuneburg comes out it's
really fascinating
she's this big climate change activists
a lot of these climate change people are
very much
apocalyptic we've got nine years to
solve this problem
think about how scary that is what
they're really saying
there are too many people they are using
too much and we have nine years to
figure it out
or else what yeah so what's that what
and then they talk about a great reset
changing capitalism well for one thing
i think it's kind of great that people
are adopting van life
like millennials are hopping in vans and
cruising and enjoying life more
and just chilling people for too long
were getting their happiness out of
things nah
man you want to sit on the beach with a
dog and look at the stars that's that's
the way to do it and that's better for
the planet everything
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you